In this problem, an unlucky individual
is exposed to a chemical at the Long Day
Factory at an intake rate of 0.00305
mg over kg days.
Based on the EPA hazard index criteria,
determine the minimum oral reference
dose in mg over kg days required such
that the adverse non-cancer health
effects are not expected.
So, this problem is actually very quick
and easy to solve.
In fact, the numerical value of the
answer is technically already given to
you.
The only requirement is that you
understand what the EPA hazard index
actually is.
This can be searched for in the
reference manual.
On page 143,
the reference manual says directly that
a hazard index greater than one
represents the possibility of an adverse
effect occurring.
The manual also provides the following
equation.
Hazard index equals chronic daily intake
in the context of non-carcinogenic
health effects
over the reference dose.
Chronic daily intake itself is not
specific to carcinogens or
non-carcinogens.
It is simply an exposure metric.
When used with the reference dose in the
hazard index equation, it is
specifically evaluating non-cancer
health risks.
These could be things like damage to
organs, neurological effects, or blood
disorders.
In reality, this means that our
reference dose has to be any number
equal to or greater than the chronic
daily intake rate in order to keep the
hazard index less than or equal to one.
And since we are asked to find the
minimum dose that will not trigger
concern,
we need to pick the value that keeps our
ratio exactly equal to one.
We can solve this out to be our second
answer, or we can simply use the value
of the intake rate if you understand the
concept already.
You may also notice the high level of
precision
among the multiple-choice answers here,
which might feel frustrating.
The level of precision in the answers
would be annoying if this was a real
calculation problem,
but the minor differences between them
are all actually intentional here to
make sure that you understand the
concept.
If we selected 0.00304,
this value is slightly lower than the
intake rate, which would make the hazard
index greater than one,
indicating the potential for adverse
effects, and therefore not meeting the
acceptable threshold.
Similarly,
if we used 0.00306,
this value is slightly higher than the
intake rate, which would make the hazard
index less than one,
meaning it is acceptable, but not the
minimum value that satisfies the
threshold condition.
So, understanding where to find hazard
index and what it is are all that it
takes to solve this problem.
If you want to learn more about the
hazard index, I will place a link to the
EPA in the caption of the video
description below.